this lecture it's I'm gonna be going
over this particular game between
Richard report and barrage abhava
so the name of this class if you can
remind me what is it called again just
in the 21st century so the reason I
picked this game is because you could
not possibly find more 21st century
players than these two
so Richard Report is a Hungarian player
who's a very very who's basically one of
the best players in the world and he's I
think not even yet 20 like very very
strong player from hungry and battered
rubaba is a bit older but also an elite
player and recently in the Olympia he
he's he won the gold for first board so
you could imagine that he had to beat a
lot of strong players but I was actually
looking forward to this cuz I'd say
among the elite players not among okay
every player every just put on the
planet probably not but amongst the
elite players these two are probably the
craziest meaning that they do not play
normal theory they kind of make things
up as they go along they're very very
creative and this type of player I would
say really didn't exist too much I would
say that they you know in coffee houses
and in you know chess club's where you
know say 1600 players you know people
around that level of playing there are
players like this but at the elite GM
level there are so few and this is
something which i think is kind of new
so I thought we'd go over this game it
was a really interesting game but some
of the decisions they make I would say
if you were to ask 9 out of 10
grandmasters they'd be like what but
these guys do it and not only do it they
do it well and they get away with it so
let's see so first of all so d69 c3 c5
so what would you guys play here is
white
and that actually perfectly good move I
like it any other good moves also an
excellent move F for of course is what
report played remember these guys are
maniacs but okay what opening does this
look like the keys give it what I find
interesting about these players is that
they they're completely modern players
but they have actually a lot of
classical leanings they like positions
like the Kings gambit which at the elite
level at least nowadays doesn't exist
but these guys still play it so pawn
takes pawn Knight f3 so how do you
normally play a Kings gambit what kind
of move do you look for here well you
took this pawn what's the idea of the
Kings gambit by the way does anyone know
usually right sometimes you can give
back the pond for example against the
Kings game but I happen to like the
system where you play d5 you exchange
that the pawns in the center and you
basically make it so white has no
initiative which you'd know about if you
attend in my last lecture but you don't
really you're not very greedy you don't
really hang on to the pump but usually
an association with d6 you play a move
like g5 and you try to grep and you try
to hang on to this pawn but it makes
sense right because this pawn is not
just a pawn it actually prevents this
Bishop from getting out so for example
after a move like d4 you can play you
know g4 by the way has to be considered
of course but even if you just play
Bishop g7 you really have a strong hold
against this bishop this bishop now
can't really develop so not only do you
take the pun but your pawns are kind of
hitting the bishop of course there are
drawbacks to playing like this which
means your King is not as good right um
but again these guys are a little cuckoo
so g5 was not played and he guesses what
black played here
alright so in 97 kind of a strange move
but the idea is to just guard this pawn
right but I really don't like this move
it just it takes way too long to guard
the pawn like this and I think it'll be
taken later anyway so d4 most played
normal
96 it's so funny too because if you saw
this position and I knew the pairings
for this round and you would ask me
which the game this came from I'd
immediately say report ciabatta would
not hesitate because only these guys can
play like this these days at the top
level again so nigh g6 Bishop d3 which
again I thought was kind of a weird move
to be perfectly honest I don't know
what's wrong with even just 95 and
taking back this pawn it looks to me
like blacks gonna have just a terrible
position because I mean look White has
the two pawns in the center right black
can't really challenge it you can just
take this pawn Bishop c4 also looks
normal but ok a report b7 castles 97 so
once again I'm curious what you guys
would play here again 95 is the move
that occurred to me I'm sorry 95 was
played it was this position where
something weird happened
yeah of course I mean I didn't even
mention that f8 which looks kind of
insane but we're all just skipping that
no I mean probably black should just
castle and say alright I'm just worse
but like what would you guys play here
is way like what's the normal move sure
I mean I understand that you let the
knight out
technically but come on you have the two
pawns in the center they're not being
challenged in any way you can move the
bishop back wherever this looks fine
white just has a very very comfortable
advantage but again these guys one of
the things that they do is they try to
not just play I mean okay a lot of
positions you have to just play good
moves you don't have a choice but one of
the things they try to do to opponents
and again it's a newer trend if they try
to kind of give them difficult choices
they try to make led difficult for them
and they also play very aggressively so
I can tell you almost for sure report
thought well this guy he's just putting
his pieces on the back rank what is he
doing he wanted to punish him really
severely so he did not take this pawn
like Queen e1 which to me looks a little
strange because I'm not exactly sure
where that guy's going just yet but
black plate 96 white took the bishop and
now the position is getting kind of
weird right it like it's not it's not
entirely clear how you're gonna win this
pawn back no so how would you proceed
well first figure out what's going on
here which by the way is not such an
easy thing to do what exactly is going
on in this strange mess of a position ah
weights down upon very true does white
have any compensation for this pop
that's a great answer can anyone be more
specific very good
so whites blacks pieces I wouldn't call
blacks pieces not active but they're a
little weird you know they're they're
not exactly I mean they're both
defending this they're doing a great job
of defending this pawn I'll put it that
way but other than that the Knights look
a little strange what is the two pawns
in the center and the two bishops also
can be very powerful with the initiative
so the question is though what should
white do should is this a position for
white to play slowly do you think why
not right now sometimes when you're down
material you have long-term compensation
so what's the difference between long
term and short term composition it's
where it's a matter of Tempe like your
opponent for example if your opponent
not being castled that's not something
that's permanent right they can probably
cancel in a move or two it means it's
going to go away which means you want to
be quick about it so the two bishops I'd
say white has some long-term
compensation the two bishops are
definitely long-term but that's about it
which means that white should really
trying to stir up an initiative so those
of you who have been here for over an
hour already know exactly how to do that
so how do you stir up an initiative
that's I stir up an initiative doesn't
necessarily mean commit suicide there's
a difference yeaji for I don't get what
you're accomplishing it looks kind of
crazy the only person who could possibly
play it is a report I will give you that
however I don't think it's a good move
and this move actually is quite good I
think well G for I think your ponds
gonna be too weak there you need it at
least one pond shielding your king so h4
is actually a very very nice move so the
reason why is because a move like a five
you know okay it technically tries to
open lines but it doesn't do that much
by itself 84 on the other hand actually
is very clever because now black has to
make a tough choice now I'm actually
very curious because what Joe Bava chose
I don't think I'd ever choose here and I
know you know it so do you quiet if you
can but try to what what exactly is
White's idea of h4 it's actually very
simple H spot to drive the night away
and maybe try to take this pump
not to mention maybe developing an
initiative now normally moving pawns in
front of your king like this can be
dangerous but remember it's a Kings
gambit you're playing for initiative and
it's not like black can really do that
much with these pieces the other nice
thing about h4 is it prevents nineteen
five ideas in some positions trying to
trade off the Knights and get out the
bishop so this move actually has a few
purposes however what would you do is
black cuz you have quite a few you don't
don't just have one option I'm pretty
sure I know what I would play but I'm
curious what you guys would play mmm I'm
with you I do not want to allow h5 I
would almost certainly play h5 myself
and I'm really not sure how black can
take it white could take advantage now
it's true this Knight now is a little
looser castling can be kind of
nerve-wracking with a pawn here but at
the same time why does a pawn here as
well I think the position is really just
a mess I don't think either side has the
advantage by the way if you had this
position as why wouldn't you really have
rather taken this pawn earlier and just
had a nice advantage for nothing but
these guys don't think about that this
way but Joe Bava chose to Castle
apparently he thought this Madden h8 was
gonna win him a beauty prize or
something but to me it looked just
really embarrassing
so I don't know I mean again it's just
the way the reason why I'm showing this
game is just because like these guys
really kind of encapsulate modern chess
almost to an extreme degree I do again I
do not think I would not choose to allow
this I don't think most grandmasters
would choose to allow this either I
don't think I'm alone on this one I
think Joe Baba's in the minority but the
point is that these guys think about
chess differently they're more like for
example a sort of I'd say chess maybe
thirty years ago they would not even
look at this and the reason why is
because oh when I don't h8 they can't
obviously get back into play maybe age
six comes maybe that for pawn hangs they
wouldn't allow it almost out of
principle like oh another neck shake it
can't be good
a lot of players still incorporate this
into their thinking but what modern
chess has more than any more than it
used to and this is obviously caused by
computers to a large extent because
computers will often tell you Oh matter
on a chain who cares now computers don't
like this I can tell you for sure but
there are some times where it's just
okay it looks ugly but you have to prove
to me it's bad and if you can't find
exact variations concrete variations
which prove it it a lot of things are
totally playable I've had it positions
where say I have a huge attack I'm like
oz has to be great the computer is just
laughing at me saying nah there's no
mate sorry or positions where I think
that I'm clearly worse than the
computers like now you can just defend
with these moves it's no big deal
and sometimes it says you know put that
on on a che who cares and it's one of
those things where in again it's it's
truly a 21st century thing because it
used to be people just didn't play these
moves on principle and again I'm talking
mostly about like you know elite
grandmasters or international master or
at least people of master level but um
you know it used to be just you don't
put pieces here now looks like it's a
pattern a change it's not gonna kill you
again I would not do it but hey he won
the game so Who am I to argue in any
case I think that blacks positions a
little suspect here I'm being kind with
that wording but
but okay the interesting thing is that
it is report which means that he's
probably gonna do something nuts anyway
so he plays he five which makes sense to
me
opening up the bishop right incidentally
I move like Queen g6 at threatening me
could be really embarrassing at the
wrong moment
so black decided he wanted to lock
things up so what would you guys play
here as well because this move would not
probably not have been my choice either
c4 is actually what was played in the
game I don't think it's a terrible move
but I don't think it would have been my
choice and the reason why is because
this position is not like the others in
that I do not see a way for black to
repair his position yes the pawn on f4
is kind of hanging things are messed up
but I just don't see a way for black to
repair I think that you do not have to
be in that much of a rush so in the
interest of taking your time what's a
clear improving move I like this move
very much I think this would have been a
little bit more dangerous actually but
okay c4 he wants to go out I'm right
away and by the way this is not totally
an inhuman way to play take six rook da
and this is the thing with these guys
which they do really well and something
which I wish I could do better actually
which is that these guys do not panic at
all one of the things about because
every single game they play insane
positions do you think they're gonna
come they're gonna go crazy if they have
a really bad position they're used to it
believe me these guys see more bad
positions than any of us probably but
there's still elite players you know
very very strong players and the reason
why is because they handle these
positions so well
rook D it's actually an excellent move
and it was really like the main way to
stay in the game here to cause problems
because now
oh I would love to play d5 but there's a
problem mm-hmm and the bishop and
so white decided to take this night but
do you think white really wanted to take
this thing probably not right because
now the light squares are pretty weak so
that's why I think playing with Bishop
d2 was a little more clever but Queen
takes Queen to h4 you could take the
pawn of course but you wanted to attack
the rook first finally he takes the pawn
after all this so what's happening here
made it what do you mean I got our net
on h8 how could I ever get made it oh no
that's what the night and f8 sorry
there's a saying actually with the net
and f8 you can't get made it within a
turn h8 I don't know if it applies but
but I would say that there are two ways
you can try to handle a piece like this
you can try to play for checkmate but
there's another way to play which I
often find is the better way to go and
actually I recently used this trick in
my other games when your opponent has a
bad piece one of the tricks you can do
is actually try to trade off every other
piece trade the rooks trade the bishops
trade everything and leave your opponent
only with their bad piece and you'll
find often you can win very easily
because they're basically playing a
piece down and I used this trick
actually in a recent game it was
actually more clear than this was but
you know it and it was but it made my
life a lot easier because basically I
was like I just wanted to trade off the
pieces I didn't even think trying to go
for the initiative or trying to go for
the throat I'm like all right I'm just
gonna trade off the pieces and leave
them with this not nh8 so it's actually
not such a bad idea however the main
thing is you want to make sure this
knight doesn't get back in the game
unless you absolutely have to make sure
that night stays out of the game if you
play a move like h6 and allow knight g6
that's probably not gonna be good for
you right because you better make sure
your mating let's put it that way
because you're letting your opponent's
piece back in the game you want to keep
this guy here as long as you can leave
it there to rot so black played Queen g4
so what now you want to take it you
don't a checkmate anymore well I guess
the alternative is playing Queen h2
which is a little embarrassing huh but
he plays rook c8 rook c1 so the Queen's
get traded now how does the Queen trade
affect the position it's actually a good
question you were gonna ask what happens
if rook takes d4 well first of all the
rook on the seventh is very strong the
other thing I would say is that you're
asking for trouble and the reason why is
because the but the game is complicated
now the pieces are interacting it's
gonna be a mess why is that so bad for
black yeah yeah this is not on a cheat
if everything goes crazy in every every
side starts making threats black's gonna
have to live with this knight on h8 it's
not gonna participate it's like having
some huge battle and some you know one
of your soldiers are just sidelined
right
you're probably gonna lose it so it's
what black's whole idea here is to keep
the position closed because then the
fact that this knight looks well
less-than-stellar is not as big of a
deal right because the positions locked
there's no way to take advantage of it
so this is a nice trick to use if you
ever end up with a piece like this we
all do once in a while
thankfully I can't remember the last
night I had like this I'm sure I've had
a few but c6 white blood please back so
now what got her to get stuff out I
assume
it's a possibility yeah black tries to
go on the initiative here which seemed a
little strange to me but again I mean
these are the moves that were to occur
to me to Bishop e6 Bishop g4 trying to
take this pawn I mean but rook b5 he he
wants to gain another temple attacking
stuff so b3 so this is actually an
interesting question why did he play
this so this is definitely possible it's
kind of weird because normally and move
like h6 is a good positional move why is
that what what pawn wedging why is this
a normal normally a good positional move
yeah so for example forget the Knights
for a moment the bishop has the holes
the King's not as comfortable this kind
of thing is usually very bad however
here black can play this which normally
is a weakening move it opens up the King
a little which even an endgame could be
a problem but this knight on h8 can now
go to g6 right so you're letting your
opponent's piece out which is why I
actually don't think white should be
playing for that so my guess would be
that javo wasn't necessarily afraid of
h6 but he thought that Bishop e6 he
could play anytime and he wanted to make
sure this pawn stayed here so that at
least in the future he had a potential
weakness again personally I think this
is a little bit dangerous because now
playing f6 is gonna be really difficult
with this pawn hanging but again that's
why these guys think a little about just
a little differently okay rook c3 so
white wants to be able to think about
attacking this rook and maybe slide the
rook over to g3 which seems pretty
logical to me so what now
this move also has a tactical point
which I'd like you to find so what's the
idea
this move asked to be considered right
because not only you're trying to win a
pawn you're trying to free your piece so
one who that has to be looked at as a
bishop takes c3 h6 so now pawn takes
this is probably very bad for you
because and if f5
there was a yeah just take them out my
trick for you was I don't know if it
works but don't allow this but you can
just take this pawn and then the bishops
gonna fall so taking this bishop back
would be ill-advised so probably you
should take here and now any ideas
ruchi three is very tempting that's for
sure but I'm curious what you do if I
just bring my night out so the funny
thing is I think that Jo bhava played
this mood rook b5 which looked a little
weird just so that after Knight f5 type
moves there was no 97 [ __ ] pretty
clever start with this so here at first
it looks like blacks totally safe right
but I don't know you have to look at
this movement
so you see how even in the endgame the
initiative can kind of persist sometimes
in this particular position I think
black maybe survives play this move the
point is that at first I thought rook
takes f7 was quite strong we'll get to
that after rook takes f7 there's this
move unfortunately without this move
white with black would we just bust it
because this bishop is gonna fall after
pawn takes I think the move is seen G so
so you probably get a queen yep
but I think that black is doing fine
here people equal material this D pawns
maybe even a little weak of anything but
okay the King comes here should be
fairly drawing so be quite a way to end
the game so actually it's a very good
question
what happens after all this I mean it
was a very long game I I analyzed
specific parts of it for the lecture
this particular this particular move I
didn't look at but it's kind of an
interesting question right because I
mean if you can't take this pot I mean
he'd love to take this pawn but I looked
at all sorts of things here like for
example after night g6 I have other
ideas to try to even like for example
Bishop takes pawn with the idea that
after a King takes Knight check and no
matter where the King moves I thought
that I could win the bishop maybe but
I'm not even sure that's possible
although after Bishop takes g7 there's
90 to h4 which actually puts a damper on
things to say the least
but even here I can't be totally sure
because after Bishop f6 maybe you can
try to play for a checkmate by bringing
your rook up so for example rook I
forward h4 rook here somewhere
these positions just get so crazy and so
fast but clearly these guys saw
something he played rook a five instead
and then wrote back to d5 so whatever it
was he did not like what he saw so white
played in that f5 so white decided no
more of that takes takes so no I still
think that white has an edge this not a
nightshade is still not fixed but it's
still it's not so easy to take advantage
of but okay in this position rook e8 g4
and I believe this was the position
where I really would not have played the
wage Obama dude the question is what can
you do here
well g6 is possible but now keep in mind
you've made this guy weaker so after
rook f6
let's see
definitely possible but you don't have a
major you're not fixing your night right
the main problem in the position you're
not fixing so let's say I improve my
peace I'll play rook back I don't know
see time until you improve that night
you're gonna have problems right that
nights just sitting on h8 hating its
life so try to try to do your friend a
few favors there yeah and you don't even
have to do it immediately but this was
definitely the idea I came in riding
with rookie six Kings you too and yeah I
think this is the position I wanted it
yep so what's the idea
apart from breaking up the pawns what's
your main goal here yeah the knight
wants to get in that's the main thing
you're accomplishing so when you have a
bad piece and this is actually a
question to always ask yourself now I'm
hoping for your six most games you do
not have a piece like the knight on h8
that's basically you don't want a piece
like that but it all in any chess
position if you're stuck if you're not
sure of what to do or what your plan
should be ask yourself what is my worst
piece and usually you'll come up with an
answer and usually improving your worst
piece is gonna be a good move often
times you know I use that technique
myself there's some position I can't
figure out ask myself what piece do I
really want to improve usually you'll
come up with an answer and improving
that piece is the key to making your
position stronger when you have a piece
like on that nh8 it's a different story
in a lot of positions say you have like
a rook on eight that's not in the game
yet sometimes you can play a couple
extra moves or even several moves
without improving that rook cuz you're
gonna prove it at any time right an i
don't h8 your mindset should be fixed
this now every single move it should be
like a red alarm bell going off in your
head fix fix fix because otherwise
you're gonna leave that night on h8 the
rest of the game and be very depressed
so f6 yes it may weaken this h6 pawn it
may have other problems but fixing this
night is completely it's so important
cuz okay white should probably
take this but now you can even take this
guy the knight comes back in I mean you
know you could even end up better if
these guys are weak sorry
uh yeah it doesn't quite work um so yeah
F sex was definitely the way to go I
think he played a six which to me is a
little nuts like you're really moving
upon over here when you're saying but
again these guys are something special
so King G Z any guess what move I would
play you guys are good all right he
played g6 which is actually interesting
but so the idea now is there's no Rock
f6 cuz this real covers so yeah I mean
this is kind of weird probably white
should actually take this
it looks really strange to let the
knight out but the point is that even
though the knight gets out black has
another severe weakness which is this
pawn on h6 is it just gonna fall so this
is another technique which you want to
be aware of which is sometimes your
opponent has something bad about their
position but they're going to fix it you
know there's nothing you can really do
about it so what you do is you actually
exchange one advantage for another in
this case you exchange the fact that
this night was bad for the fact that
this pawn is not weak and you're
probably gonna win it I've never easily
go to let a piece like this back in the
game so I really don't blame him for
playing a move like this
he played rook f3 instead which makes
sense right he wants to keep this Knight
bad but unfortunately for him it's not
so easy pawn takes pawn and f6 and he
finally this nights gonna come back into
the game
so taking probably way too many moves
but the key is that eventually he really
what did want to fix this name so rook
takes takes takes so now what
in this position it's possible but I
think you might experience some problems
here because after pawn takes pawn okay
so unfortunately your rooks your bishops
detect and I'm threatening pawn takes
pawn and then I might be the one playing
for the win no so and in fact that's
exactly the kind of thing that happened
rook takes rook takes h5 and here was
actually it's time to get to important
moments because what's happened what's
transformed in the position right I
would say that these two pawns these two
pawns I think are fine but these two
pawns in particular I think are very
weak so for example if we get a position
even if these guys trade and I end up
with a net on d5 you could end up
defending for a long time and these are
the type of danger positions where I
think that a lot of players will mess
them up which is that your position was
so good it was so promising but now all
of a sudden it's a mess it's so easy to
think to kind of go into the mindset of
you know you're still trying to win a
position you shouldn't win it's so hard
to kind of transform your thinking
because white had such a big advantage
for so long but he loud f6 he allowed
the game to transform he allowed all of
this to happen so now the game's changed
and white has to actually be the one
who's careful so the question is what
should white play here
very nice
so the idea now is if the rook moves
away what happens
it's okay but you're trying to get this
rook into the game right
rookie fives possible but I'd like to
play d5 myself trade off your weak pawn
right take stakes and all of a sudden
the rook comes to d7 I mean black
White's doing totally okay right what
happens if I take your rook yeah so
probably you'll end up in an ending like
this now you have to be careful this
pawn is kind of a little bit bad but
it's probably better than on on d4 right
so the King kind of slides over the
bishop can guard it I mean probably at
least the [ __ ] that's at least a
holdable endgame right right I mean once
the King gets here it's gonna be pretty
hard to win probably the King I'll even
stay on e4 to keep this King up but the
point is that it becomes drawable but
again I think that he wasn't thinking in
these terms necessarily just yet
he played King g4 and did this yeah so
here I didn't get why he didn't move his
king up almost always you want an active
King in the endgame maybe he was afraid
of this and honestly it actually is a
very human decision because this bishop
looks pretty bad to me but at the same
time I think that he really had no
choice and the bishop can get back it's
not like it can ever get back but he
played backwards and now he ended up at
least having to defend because even
though you're the one with the passed
pawn this pawn is clearly a weakness not
a strength right so king g4 so yeah here
was another moment where I thought he
had to backtrack be like okay I'm gonna
play three versus two but he gets
something similar to this so sorry I'm
going fast but the end of the game is
kind of complicated and I wanted to
cover it yeah this is another thing 95
was kind of a mean move because normally
would you like to trade the bishop for
the knight as white it's actually an
interesting question
why
I'd say kind of I'd say it really varies
but in general yes you want to aim for
the rook endgame rook game games in
general tend to be very Jewish when you
have all pawn all pawns on one side a
knight sometimes it's better than a
bishop but it will give at least greater
winning chances yeah but don't trade the
rooks trading the rooks is gonna be very
bad actually if you trade the rooks you
might be able to hold with like King on
c2 if you trade the bishop for the night
you should almost certainly be able to
hold well you'll not be able to hold as
the King upon endgame that will be lost
every time and it's just one of those
things like if you're down upon and I
keep on ending with lots of puns left
it's I mean you have to calculate it but
I would say you know almost a hundred
percent you're just gonna lose almost
all of them so the key is to either have
a rock end game or Bishop against Knight
if you have to but the reason why Java
played Bishop e5 here is cuz Bishop
takes rook takes is a mistake because
yeah you have to trade the Rose right so
that's why he waited until King e2 to
play 95 so he played rookie 4 instead 93
so they got this kind of position
and here probably black should actually
have played night a two and night back
and then kind of continued you know
blacks obviously better trying to win
but it's not clear that black can
actually accomplish this but it's one of
those positions if you're black you play
forever if you're white and if you have
to defend forever and it's just you know
if the King could get back probably
you're drawing but it's still not going
to be that easy but note how this Kings
cut off as well so again it's just tough
but Chi Baba decided to trade off the
rooks and at first this looks like a
great decision because after this he
plays here and he wins upon by force but
believe it or not because White has
better King position white should
actually draw this just because this
king is so close but what it means is
that White has to play accurately so
here's my question
and I'll even flip the board just for
you guys how does white draw because it
is really not easy
and to give you an idea of how not easy
it is he lost in a matter of a few moves
just you know lighten your spirits
well you correctly remembered the game
played the move played and then what
happened was a five looks like a nice
move right securing these pawns ready to
take them the problem is that the king
will simply head for b5 so he played a
different move here but after King b6
King c4
everything's held together perfectly
right and the knight can just take this
pawn at will this pawn can be pushed you
have no chance so that would be an
example of what not to do so a5 is not
the best move
there are many so let me show you kind
of where the problems are so first of
all if you allow black too much time the
King will simply come in and you're not
gonna have a chance so you have to go
after these pawns right and it's what he
should have played for sure so there are
a couple different defenses King e6 and
Keeney for let's go for King e4 but here
is where do not rush there are many many
moves all of which look reasonable only
one of them drawers oh yeah you guys
thought you're gonna have it easier
tonight
I just gave you like the hardest problem
of the night you come up with an answer
in like a second all right fine
I'm afraid to play it though because
then you'll see them alright Bishop d6
let's analyze Bishop d6 Knight b3 Knight
d3 check King d5 the fact that you
allowed a tempo move probably means
you're already losing right and this is
one of the key things to learn when
you're choosing a square for the bishop
like if you do choose a bishop move here
the key is that you have to it's almost
always important to be accurate because
for example if you put on a square where
a king can attack it while improving
itself you probably just gave up a whole
temple position like this you can't
afford to go up a whole temple but let's
look at the most direct room first King
b6 the most direct right you're just
gonna go after these pawns and say
whatever I'm going to take your pawns
and drop it would be wonderful
however what happens after King 2b 609 a
- so what's the idea of that a - if I
play King b6 you mean from the beat 4
squares what you're saying
it's an interesting idea actually
because after night a to King bee six
King defy if to its waster sorry yeah
but after where you go after King b6 in
that a - I see yeah because if King
takes pawn Knight before Bishop d6
there's a five but then I can attack
you're a fun so you don't quite have
time to hold the pawns that way but
you're actually that's an important idea
the key is that the knight here is not
stable right the question is what is the
stable square very nice if you get
Knight b3 pawn on a5 King d5 is just
over because the pattern a5 is secure
the pawn can just push all right let's
examine the moves one by one after king
b6 King defy vis the move with the idea
that takes an a5 then Knight to b3
pushpa so that does not work
that's true yeah and a teeny six this
move is actually very strong so the King
here now yeah Bishop g3 but the reason
why this is the move is not so simple so
yeah King b6 doesn't work so you need to
find a bishop move but for example most
squares are bad for example Bishop c7
occurred to me I mean it keeps an eye on
the pawns right makes sense the problems
with the bishop here is that after
Knight b3 the King goes the King has to
go back right because of King p6 you
play which move I was singing King d5 or
a5 rather right
if King B 605 takes King d5 the same
position the knight guards the pawn this
pawns ready to roll right so the King
goes back and now the problem is the
neck goes here so King c5 looks like a
reasonable move but it has a problem
with it correct which is why this is not
a good square see what I mean so Bishop
h2 trying to get it so out of the way
makes sense but now there's actually a
way to win you play naive you check c5
and the bishop cannot get back correct
if King takes you're actually a very
nasty move if c3 then Bishop d6 holds by
the way but you play check first and
then c3
and now the king can the bishop can't
get back to God this one very
embarrassing
so quite the variation now this is why
you have to go to g3 by the way
Dodd's of finding this in a game not
very high even for players of this
caliber
however it's monly mostly to show like
how precise you have to be and this is
something which you know it's it's so
difficult to do even with time but the
key is you need to use a technique which
is basically process of elimination is
the way to find this you're not going to
find this move out of sheer brilliance
if you can find this move out of sheer
brilliance then you're on your way to be
challenging Carlsen um however the
easiest way to find this move is to
eliminate moves king b6 we saw just lost
right Bishop c7 we calculated lost
Bishop h2 is more complex but you can
calculate that as well when you start
eliminating possibilities you have to go
well what's left right Bishop g3 ends up
being your only move sounds very
exhausting and it is but it's actually
sometimes easier to eliminate moves than
it is to calculate the correct one so
oftentimes if you're looking and looking
and looking and your times ticking down
go with the move you're not sure doesn't
work right any move you know loses and
it's pretty obvious I mean don't bother
right keep looking and find the move
which at least is challenging Bishop g3
believe it or not holds the draw here so
the idea is that if make t3 check now
and you go down this whole path it
doesn't work because in this position
Knight c5 check that fails and why is
that
yeah and then c3 trying to clean again
yes
notice how the bishop on h2 could not
get there and this you should be able to
hold easy to hold is it anyways um so
that doesn't work knight b3 check looks
like a reasonable try but then the King
goes back again back 85 so if King B 693
again but you have this move and now
Knight B through check King back to c4
and you actually hold I'm actually very
curious about this now now that you were
claiming it was so easy I want to test
you so I want to play 95 go ahead
so show me how easy this is you say you
should never lose this right okay go
ahead
that you do I cannot deny that you have
an apron but I think you're actually
losing because 92 cannot be stopped
which means where did we make the
mistake 95 check no all right
where to go
you lose your palm but is that the end
of the world
not quite but you remember you don't
actually have to you don't actually have
to win you don't have to use your pond
necessarily to draw you just have to get
your king and Bishop to make sure the C
pawn doesn't clean all right hold on
sorry
so c2 Bishop here can you finish so
Bishop I think go away that's kind of
rude all right fine I'll go I'll go away
so the idea by the way is that if here
in this position King b3 and King b2 I
was thinking though Bishop back to c1 so
now the bishop can negate there's no
blocking but what's the idea after king
b6 and I push again and I try the same
winning method I did before
and what's the difference because the
king up still lose sorry
yes it does
if a seven Queen here if King be seven I
check and by the way you guys know if
the pawn gets to a seven it's a draw
right with the King here but
unfortunately with the pond and a six
that is a win so what do you do
mmm
oh I actually figured it out king b5 is
fun I fed you the wrong move
disdaining song
I did they should be ones not only move
so just to show you guys what we're
talking about
after c2 now the bishop guards from this
square so when you play knight b3 you
don't gain a temple on the bishop which
means you can push your pawn pushing the
pawn works it's not winning but now you
can take and play the a to a7 now one
extra tempo is all it takes Bishop h4 is
actually very clear and the idea is that
now if you play Knight d3 for example
you play this move with the idea that
now on c2 you can at least shimmy back
and hold but you can see how and by the
way even this is not even close to the
tip of the iceberg as far as calculating
this so again you can see why it's not
like well Bishop g3 how can you possibly
see all this in the game I mean there's
no way I would see all this zero chance
and that's if I had 45 minutes the key
is how do you figure it out how do you
find this kind of move the way and how
could report have avoided this now
probably using time pressure that didn't
help the key is you have to figure out
okay a5 it loses to this very direct
method King b6 loses to this very direct
method so you find the only thing which
struggles which keeps up the fight which
makes it so that you can't lose and I'd
say that that kind of practical thinking
is if anything a definition of modern
chess because it used to be they try to
solve it but as weak as we can see it's
just often not possible so using
techniques like process of elimination
and making sure you you know look at all
the you know you basically just
eliminate everything that's not
completely losing it's the way to go
anyway very long crazy game not as
organized as usual but I feel like if if
all of my notes were really organized
they wouldn't pay homage to these
players
you